Magnus plundered a pawn  it's a queen end game oh we have a fun  move yeah  I'm excited  have fun for your cash again yeah he's  giving away oh it's off oh it's off the  board so the maximum this game could go  is to move 190. okay 50 move countdown  let's count a lot of videos  all right okay 49.  this is what commentating about how long  has it been now I wish we were paid by  the move oh imagine how rich we would be  48. if I'm ever commentating on your  game David I'm going to put a clause on  your hair  in the contract  okay he's not going to accept that  Trader Rooks he's not cutting this one  short Richard okay  and big threat on the board the rook and  the King they're on the same diagonal  so the bishop can Retreat to the